eine weiß gewandete gestaltet am sonntag
durch fast menschenleere straßen roms
der weg führt in die kirche san angelo
alcott es ist papst franziskus er hat
den vatikan verlassen und zu beten für
die opfer des corona wir uns und für ein
ende der pandemie
dort kniete er nieder vor einem kreuz
aus den zeiten der pest epidemien
kulturplatz heute ganz im zeichen von
corona
[Musik]
und dieser kulturplatz heute der findet
bei mir zu hause statt moderation im
home office also corona hat unser aller
leben fest im griff frontier bei mir im
wohnzimmer haben meine töchter die
besten plätze belegt homeschooling
flüchten ist für mich unmöglich wohin
denn auch alles geschlossen die welt
steht still und auch der kulturbetrieb
die restaurants die theater die museen
das kino alles geschlossen wie gehen die
kreativen mit diesem extremen
ausnahmezustand um dazu unser
schwerpunkt heute das konzerthaus mut in
zürich nach der schließung am montag
steht fest
62 konzerte sind bis im mai abgesagt
was danach passiert ist vermutlich in
karen super ungewiss also sie zwei
wochen sehen wir einfach vor stunde zu
stunde mit der krise umgingen und mit
der neue maßnahmen mit abartigen mit der
absage für die internationale band für
kulturbetrieb ist schwierig man muss
wissen dass klubs in der schweiz
meistens zehn prozent der mitarbeiter
sind fest angestellt und jetzt
prozentige verschaffen die oder sei es
barmitarbeiter technik gerade in
oberkassel puffer securities dass sie
alles mit 1 2 durch stunden oder
tageslohn art wie sie sind und sie sind
auch selbstständig also es wird nicht
einfach in dieser krise geht es auch
darum den kontakt zur bevölkerung zu
hause nicht zu verlieren
dank dem 2017 installierten livestream
studio wären geister konzerte möglich
und alle seite aufgenommen konzerte
stehen online zur verfügung
wir werden natürlich unsere plattform
was schon geht's los punkte getan dass
ich eine plattform an sich abonnieren
aus dem raum wie auch netflix woche als
monats oder jahres abo kaufen und
konzert nur der baum schon oft genannt
werden mehr als 500 online stellen und
selbst vor der ihnen vorteile plattform
können stadtmusik übertrug sind also
werden wir das voll pushen und weil wie
gemacht dafür dann sogar mit etwas
unterstützung musiker schafft
unterstützen
für theaterfans steht die berner
online-plattform spector zur verfügung
das ziel ist die vernetzung und
archivierung der bühnenkunst im
deutschsprachigen raum
eigentlich ein paar monaten geplant geht
die seite bereits jetzt online
da auch die proben teilweise nicht mehr
stattfinden können geschweige denn die
aufführungen haben die immerhin die
möglichkeit aufgrund der bestehenden
inszenierungen zu gucken was auf den
bühnen stattgefunden hat und dass es bei
über 8.500 inszenierungen allein im
deutschsprachigen raum
doch eine ganze menge doch funktioniert
theater überhaupt online alleine zu
hause auf dem sofa theater ist
tatsächlich ein wirklich live und das
ist auch das wunderbare an theater und
ich würde auch niemals theater ersetzen
wollen
es geht tatsächlich eher darum dass man
theater überhaupt sehen kann
kultur geht digital auch bei den museen
auf twitter gibt es bereits den hashtag
music from home bedeutende häuser
weltweit forcieren nun ihren
online-auftritt auch beim schweizer
landesmuseum sind virtuelle führungen
mit den kuratoren geplant die gerade
eröffnete ausstellung übernommen im
mittelalter kann so trotzdem noch an die
leute kommen und vor allem an die vielen
schülerinnen und schüler zu hause
priorität haben die im moment
lehrerinnen und lehrer die sind ja jetzt
viele situation dass sie mit
online-angebot anbieter und da wir
helfen indem er seine stelle wo sie mit
der schüler in der ahl werke digital und
zum beispiel stelle geschichte schweiz
wo man einen staatskunst machen
virtuell wo man erklärvideos erstellt
und wo man somit der schüler kann locker
doch nicht nur die großen
kulturinstitutionen gehen online
im netz wimmelt es nur so von kreativen
eigeninitiativen die macher dieses
online literaturfestivals stammen von
der schweizer literatur zeitschrift
glamour
ein anderes beispiel star pianist igor
levit gibt jeden abend ein live konzert
auf twitter
die italienische sängerin gianna nannini
hat auf instagram ein
solidaritätskonzert für ihre landsleute
gestreamt und die kulturwelt reagiert
auch mit humor
[Musik]
humor kann helfen reicht aber nicht aus
wer crowdfundings und online-petitionen
organisieren sich immer mehr
kultursparten denn was es jetzt braucht
ist finanzielle sicherheit
jetzt geht zum künstlerinnen und
künstler musiker und musikerinnen jetzt
gar zum institutionen wie
liquiditätsengpass habe das gebäude kurz
darum ich habe ich bin wohl ein
wahnsinnig guter künstler aber es sind
alle engagement woche trainiere eine
sprache das passiert relativ
und jetzt das fragen sich auch die
beiden schauspieler sonja riesen und
mathis künzler
eigentlich hätte das paar in den monaten
einem neuen theaterstück in bern
mitgespielt
eigentlich haben sie freischaffend und
das ist mir sehr schlecht abgesichert
als schauspieler im vorjahr in der
theaterszene und stadttheater als gast
hat man keine garantie für höhere gewalt
gegen vertragsklauseln wurde zum zuge
kommen und der zahlt leiden immer not
macht bekanntlich erfinderisch
so haben sie sich entschieden ihren nun
gewonnene zeit sinnvoll zu nutzen
das kochen bringen das machen wir mit
[Gelächter]
alle augen richten sich in dieser krise
auf den bund
das bundesamt für kultur schreibt das
frühestmögliche informationen über
dringliche massnahmen folgen jetzt
station nothilfe und nachher wieder
verlauf rost ganz gut zurecht damit aber
jetzt muss man nur das netbook der
kulturen musikszene was immer das ziel
die kulturelle vielfalt ist damit sie
dort aus dem rest kann schaden errichtet
wo man sich dann quasi album zu
schreiben
es steht viel auf dem spiel
egal ob hoch oder populärkultur
[Musik]
der kulturbetrieb trotz der korona krise
außer momentan mit humor
mit kreativität und auch mit hilfe der
digitalisierung aber wie sieht das ganze
in einigen wochen aus wir sind ja erst
bei tag 2 seitdem lockdown ja ich
persönlich bin ja noch ganz guter dinge
beende hier mein winter strikt projekt
heute geht es mir noch gut aber wir
werden die kommenden wochen mit den
geschlossenen schulen mit der selbst
verordneten isolation wie verändert
corona unser leben
befreites vergnügen war gestern heute
dominiert die stille beliebte orte sind
plötzlich wie leergefegt die korona
pandemie zwingt uns ins private sei es
erzwungen in quarantäne
oder weil wir uns freiwillig in
zurückhaltung üben bei uns und in
unseren nachbarländern
der bundesrat hat heute entschieden die
situation als außerordentliche lage zu
erklären
die regelung gilt ab mitternacht und
dauert vorerst bis 19 april den
schwächsten den älteren menschen die
menschen mit vorerkrankungen hilft man
am besten wenn soziale kontakte so weit
wie möglich gemieden werden die
bewegungsfreiheit muss eingeschränkt
werden das bedeutet bleiben sie zu hause
nun ist klar was das bedeutet wenn
museen schulen theater restaurants der
ganze länder dicht machen
wir schließen grenzen und haustüren
sie haben quasi das gegenteil der
sogenannten netzwerk effekte die wir im
netz immer positiv finden jetzt sehen
wir plötzlich dass diese netzwerkeffekte
auch sehr negativ sein können für ein
und das glaube ich ist etwas was im
augenblick mit uns passiert das
grundlegende auffassung über das wie wir
in einer modernen vernetzten welt leben
in frage stehen
und das finde ich eigentlich auch auf
eine bestimmte weise ganzen haben wir
angst vor der einsamkeit vor dem
dauernden beieinandersein uns aushalten
zu müssen
oder könnte es auch darum gehen in der
sozialen isolation ein neues
gleichgewicht zu finden fragt der
philosoph dieter thoma ich glaube dass
es eine wiederherstellung der balance
schon sein kann nämlich eine balance
zwischen dem sich herumtreiben auf dem
globalen markt auf der einen seite und
dem auf sich hören dem in sich gehen und
vielleicht auch mal dem lesen und dem
mit sich selbst beschäftigen auf der
anderen seite ich befürchte dass wir uns
schwer tun weil wir nämlich dann jetzt
als allererstes die globalisierung
künstlich ins wohnzimmer reinholen indem
wir anfangen zu stream ohne ende und
praktisch gar nicht diesen moment zu
lassen der vielleicht panik erst mal auf
erstmal auslöst nämlich dass wir ganz
auf uns gestellt sind
manch einer wird von der sehnsucht nach
dem guten alten zeiten befallen
aber ob corona für familien idylle
sorgen wird vielleicht geht es ja darum
einen neuen umgang miteinander zu finden
unsere lebensweisen zu hinterfragen
konsum
grenzen
globalisierung als stichworte um neue
perspektiven auszuloten
wir reden seit vielen jahren davon dass
wir das leben verlangsamen müssten dass
wir unsere mobilität einschränken müssen
und jetzt sind wir in dieser situation
dass das beste was wir tun können
entschleunigung ist und der rückzug ist
und das kann man sagen das ist doch eine
chance die es zu nutzen gilt
gewohntes gilt nicht mehr
krisen zeigen auch außergewöhnliches im
miteinander auf nun halt ganz privat
kreativ gelebt musizierend auf balkonien
zb corona hat uns aufgeschreckt jede und
jeden von uns es gilt jetzt diese zeit
zu nutzen
für die reflexion
daraus zu lernen für das leben danach
trotz des schreckens von grad jetzt
das ist eine angst die uns wirklich so
in den knochen steckt das wir geht es
nicht mehr sagen können irgendwann ist
es vorbei und wir atmen auf sondern sie
fordert uns auf eine verrückte weise
heraus erwachsen zu werden nämlich mit
der möglichkeit umzugehen dass man etwas
machen kann obwohl man die sache selber
nicht grundsätzlich von der welt
verschwinden lassen kann und das ist das
was erwachsene menschen tun dass dinge
die eine wirkliche gefahr darstellen
versuchen abzuwenden r tragbar zu machen
und gleichzeitig wissen es gibt keine
zuckersüße medizin und mit einem
teelöffel zucker und dann ist alles
[Musik]
keine vergnügungen in der außenwelt
keine reisen nur das nötigste kaufen ja
corona zwingt uns zum verzicht und unter
normalen umständen würden wir so was
vielleicht aus alternative lebensweise
begrüßen wie verhält es sich eigentlich
mit unserem konsumverhalten darüber
denkst der historiker frank trennt man
schon länger nach nur jetzt ist das
besonders spannend sein buch herrschaft
der dinge zu lesen
mein plädoyer ist nicht den konsum
abschaffen zu wollen das ist meiner
ansicht nach total unrealistisch und
jede bewegung die das versucht hat in
den letzten 500 jahren ist nach kurzer
zeit im nichts verschwunden und hatte
nichts erreicht konsum ohne ende
die korona krise scheint dem historiker
recht zu geben
geschlossene geschäfte und ein online
handel der immer mehr bucht frank
trentmann wert an der universität london
hat unsere lust am kaufen und
verbrauchen seit dem 15 jahrhundert
erforscht
aber von vorne konsumieren vom
lateinischen konsum ish damit hatte
einst eine ganz andere bedeutung von
station war der begriff für tuberkulose
der verbrauch der verzehr des eigenen
körper ist und dann sehen wir am 17 und
18 jahrhundert wirklich so einen
mentalitätswandel philosophen wie david
hume philosophen die sich über
wirtschaft gedanken machen wie adam
smith in seinem wohlstand der nation die
sagen halt stopp ist das alles wirklich
so negativ
konsum ist besser als sein ruf
zivilisiert uns bereichert unsere
fantasie wir konsumieren weil wir sind
weil wir sein wollen
luxus shoppen vorräte hamster darf man
das und die globalen lieferketten haben
sie die ausweitung von kubik 19
befördert aktuelle fragen und auch alte
fragen also die moralische debatte über
den konsum
diese wippe zwischen kritik und skepsis
auf der einen seite und
fortschrittsglaube und dem verlangen
nach mehr
diese wippe können wir durch die ganzen
jahrhunderte seit seit 1600 ungefähr
verfolgen herrschaft der dinge zeichnet
unsere besitz begierde durch die
jahrhunderte nach enthüllt wie sie zum
treiber der technischen entwicklung
wurde bei der mode das interessante ist
dass wir häufig denken massenkonsum ist
ein resultat der industriellen
revolution als ob es erst fabriken
gegeben haben muss und dann konnten die
menschen billig modische produkte
kaufen das ist aber verkehrt die
reihenfolge ist genau umgekehrt also der
massenkonsum an baumwolle modischen
baumwoll tüchern
den gab es schon um 1700 bevor die
großen industrie fabriken produzierten
und das hat einen einfachen grund das
natürlich auch viele viele viele kleine
handwerksbetriebe damals in indien
genauso gut oder besser
modische produkte produzieren können die
geschichte des konsums zu kennen
bedeutet uns selbst besser zu verstehen
konsumieren ein spiel mit starken
symbolen die uns oft die sicht auf die
wirklichkeit vernebeln die meisten
menschen wenn sie über konsum nachdenken
denken sehr schnell und insbesondere
wenn sie über konsum und moral denken in
die richtung des luxus die handtaschen
und die armbanduhren das natürlich alles
wichtig aber wer von der umwelt her
denken sind dinge wie heizen und kühlen
viel wichtiger die jetzige generation
zum beispiel hat gewohnheiten sich an
erlernt die vor 30 40 jahren den meisten
menschen als pervers vorgekommen werden
wie zum beispiel mehrmals am tag duschen
das durchschnittliche einkommen eines
schweizer privathaushalts aktuell rund
7000 franken
5300 davon geben wir für güter und
dienstleistungen aus
konsum bleibt trotz corona weil unsere
lust unsere gier nach neuem
auch bleibt unglücklicherweise sind wir
nicht in einer neuen welt wir sind
weiterhin in der konsumwelt die sich
über 500 jahre lang aufgebaut hat da
gibt es natürlich immer veränderungen
aber wir sehen nicht an einem punkt wo
es eine radikale neuorientierung gibt
der schwerpunkt ist dass wir
konsequenzen haben für die umwelt aber
das hat den konsum nicht
zurückgeschraubt was also tun
antizipieren und wirklich debattieren
vielleicht befeuert corona tatsächlich
unsere ideen etwa wenn es um die zukunft
der mobilen gesellschaft geht nötig wäre
es allemal denn wir sind noch immer in
alten mustern verhaftet ganz ganz
schnell wird es eine debatte
nein wir stellen von diesel auf
elektroautos um also die grundannahme da
ist dass die produkte und technologien
andere werden aber dass wir eigentlich
so weiter machen können wie wir jetzt
leben und da meine ich eben halt
vielleicht erst mal einen schritt zurück
gehen und sich überlegen was ist
eigentlich ein lebenswerter form von
mobilität frank trentmann es ansatz ist
ungewohnt
beim konsum schauen immer alle nach
vorne er hat sich für den rückspiegel
entschieden
dieser blick lohnt sich seine
historische perspektive liefert the big
picture und zeigt was positiver konsum
ein
mein plädoyer ist er für soll ein einen
intensiveren tieferen konsum lesmo
würden wir sagen im englischen also man
kann mit einer geringeren anzahl von
konsum und freizeitaktivitäten kann man
trotzdem mehr genuss herausholen und
dass wir lernen müssten
teil dieser muße uns zurück zu
erarbeiten
frank trentmann lehrt ja in london wie
wir gehört haben ja und dort ist der
umgang mit corona gelinde gesagt ein
ganz anderer
am wochenende wurde tatsächlich nahe
london noch ein halbmarathon gestartet
die briten sie in den dreck zieht also
auch bei corona durch und so feierte am
montag die große tizian ausstellung in
der national gallery ihre eröffnung nur
um heute wieder zu schließen wie er von
der schweiz aus reiben uns erstaunt die
augen einerseits über das britische
vorgehen zu zeiten der pandemie
andererseits über die großartige malerei
[Musik]
in der korona krise gibt sich london
anfangs woche noch unaufgeregt frische
luft masken eher vereinzelt und in der
national gallery hochstimmung
ein kunsthistorischer traum wird
wirklichkeit seit mehr als 400 jahren
hängen die berühmten poesie gemälde von
tizian erstmals wieder so wie einst
gedacht alle in einem raum
wir sind die ersten die das zusehen
dürfen
es ist großartig tizian selbst sah seine
bilder nie so aber er war sich über den
effekt natürlich im klaren bestellt von
spaniens philipp dem zweiten arbeitete
der künstler aus venedig ab 1551 an den
großformatigen bildern der auftraggeber
hatte ihm freie hand gelassen
der wartet dennoch was philipp gefallen
musste geschichten von liebe und
begehren schönen frauen sex und jagt das
hobby des königs
tizian inspiriert von ovids
metamorphosen lebendigen erzählungen der
götter sagen
fast wie ein filmregisseur setzt tizian
die dramatischen geschichten ins bild
voller mitleid zeigt er europa die von
dem als bullen getarnten jupiter
getäuscht entführt und vergewaltigt wird
der raum europas ist eine offenbarung
niemand hat das bild jesu nage sie denn
es hängt im gardner museum in boston
ganz weit oben
so wie es das testament von evobus
stewart gardner festlegt man kann also
nicht nahe an
mit eigenen augen sah actelion die
keusche göttin diana und ihrem neffen
nackt beim bade
dass es ein versehen war half ihm nicht
im bild versuchte jana gerade noch sich
zu verhüllen ihre fürchterliche sache
deutet der maler aber schon an
[Musik]
sie verwandelt den eindringling in einen
hirschen und lässt ihn die tizian in
einem späteren bild zeigt von hunden
zerreißen
diese bilder drehen sich darum wie alles
im leben veränderungen unterworfen ist
sowohl in der natur als auch in unserem
innenleben
die dinge können sich von etwas
erhabenem und erfreulichen in nur einem
momenten etwas schreckliches verwandeln
es geht darum wie unser schicksal wegen
er die wir nicht erwartet haben
all diese dinge von denen das leben nur
so stark
das passt zur aktuellen lage denn die
sensation hat die rechnung ohne die
ironie des lebens gemacht
ausgerechnet jetzt da es endlich
gelungen ist die poesie aus der ganzen
welt zusammen zu bringen droht das
corona virus zu spalten
denn seit neuestem schließen auch museen
in großbritannien wie eben jetzt
tizian übrigens starb zwar erst im hohen
alter von weit über 80 allerdings auch
an den folgen einer pandemie wie corona
eine ist der pest den krisenzeiten
behalten wir uns an die klassiker nach
tizian haben wir gleich noch ein genie
für sie im programm ludwig van beethoven
könnte dieses jahr seinen 200
fünfzigsten geburtstag feiern und man
könnte meinen wir wissen alles über ihn
aber weit gefehlt sehen sie zum ausklang
nach einem beitrag über den großen
ludwig und kommende woche
da sehen wir uns hoffentlich wieder
bleiben sie gesund
[Musik]
man muss nicht lange suchen um dem
zweifellos berühmtesten man bonds zu
begegnen
die deutsche staat ist nicht groß sein
geburtshaus ganz frisch herausgeputzt
einige ikonen sind nun ausgeliehen nach
nebenan zu bewundern in der
bundeskunsthalle eigentlich denn die
ausstellung ist wegen corona seit dem
wochenende geschlossen sauste mähne
entschlossener blick gemalt von josef
kral spieler das bild dass unsere
vorstellung vom unbändigen cheney von
superstar beethoven bis heute prägt
[Musik]
da deutet darum möchte das ist also
sogar vierter aber die reichen und zu
sagen das ist betroffen matthias henkel
bringt eines von schier unzähligen
beethoven büchern auf den markt
hinter all der großen musikalischen
revolution menschelte es in seiner
biografie
zum glück
er hat eine große emotionale bandbreite
also wir haben einerseits das alberne
bei ihm aber andererseits auch dass wir
selber zu geben weil dann übermaß an
jetzt schon so kann man es vielleicht
ein wenig etwas nicht passte dann konnte
er sind brutal werden auf anfang
der kleine louis wächst in einer sehr
musikalischen familie auf großvater und
vater sind musiker am kurfürstlichen hof
haben die große zeit miterlebt als ball
noch mittelpunkt gesellschaftlichen
lebens war
mit zwölf komponiert ludwig drei
klavierstücke die sogenannten kurfürsten
sonaten und bewirbt sich damit quasi bei
hofe zwei jahre später wird er
angestellt der herrscher max franz
erkennt sein talent und schickt ihn mit
21 zum studium zu joseph haydn nach wien
als in wien eintraf hat er zwei wege
unternommen die ich für bemerkenswert
hält also erst zum perückenmacher
gegangen das kann man sich gar nicht
vorstellen wie ich drauf und perücke ja
das geht irgendwie gar nicht und er ist
ein tanzlehrer gegangen also wie man
lesen kann konnte er sich gut bewegen im
takt und diese lücke eine
gesellschaftlich würde ja auch wollte er
ausgleichen
beethoven will dazugehören braucht
adelige unterstützung verbiegen lässt er
sich aber nicht
für diese schweine spiele ich nicht soll
aber unaufmerksamen publikum gesagt
haben es gibt schilderungen hatte einer
gräfin von thun hat ja die hat ihn
angefleht auf den knien das gespielt und
er hat es nicht getan
beethoven bleibt in wien ein zurück in
seine heimat
unmöglich französische truppen besetzen
das rheinland turbulente politische
zeiten beethoven liefert den passenden
soundtrack die verlage reißen sich darum
seine kompositionen zu veröffentlichen
ich fordere und matzeit schreibt er an
einen freund
das gab aufführung um mehrere tausend
menschen dann später da waren und das
ist ja ein allzeit wir müssen uns das so
vorstellen es gab ja keine medien nicht
alles abrufbar sondern man konnte es an
einem bestimmten ort hören vielleicht
einmal im jahr und da haben die leute
auch bereit preise zu bezahlen aus dem
bett of matter gut zugelangt werden wir
platz sagen
schon mit ende 20 beginnt er sein gehör
zu verlieren eigentlich ist er ständig
krank trinkt viel zu viel alkohol aber
bleibt ein macher zieht allein in wien
über 70 mal um meine haushaltung
schreibt er sieht einem schiffbruch
beinahe ganz ähnlich oder neigt dazu als
beethoven mit 56 stirbt gleich sein
leichenzug einem staatsakt der superstar
tritt ab
[Applaus]
[Musik]